It was,
we got very interested in dreams and
started to understand the relationship
between dreams and myths because he
would see in his client's dreams,
echoes of stories that he knew because
he was deeply read in mythology and,
and then he started to believe that the
dream was the birthplace of the myth and
that there was a continual
interaction between the two processes,
the dream and the story
and storytelling and well,
you know,
you tend to tell your dreams as
stories when you remember them.
And some people remember
dreams all the time,
like two or three at night.
I've had clients like that and they often
have archetipal dreams that have very
clear mythological structures.
I think that's more the case
with people who are creative,
by the way,
especially if they're a bit unstable at,
at the time,
because the dream tends to occupy the
space of uncertainty and to concentrate on
fleshing out the unknown reality
before you get a real grip on it.
So it's like the dream is
the birthplace of thinking.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
And so because it's the
birthplace of thinking,
it's not that clear.
It's doing its best to formulate something
that was Young's notion as opposed to
Freud who believed that
there were sensors,
internal sensors that
were hiding the dreams.
True message.
That's not what you and believed.
He believed the dream was
doing its best to excel,
to express a reality that was still
outside of fully articulated conscious
comprehension.
It was cause you think,
look a thought appears in your head,
right?
That's obvious pit bang.
It's it.
It's nothing you ever ask about.
But what the hell does that mean?
A thought appears in your head.
What kind of ridiculous
explanation is that?
You know,
it just doesn't help with anything.
Where does it come from?
Well nowhere.
It just appears in my head.
Okay,
well that's not a very sophisticated
explanation as it turns out.
You know?
And so you might think
that those thoughts,
thoughts that you think,
well where do they come from?
Well they're often
someone else's thoughts,
right?
Someone Long Dad,
that might be part of it.
Just like the words you use to think our
utterances of people who've been long
dead.
And so you're informed by
the spirit of your ancestors.
That's one way of looking at it.
And your motivation,
speak to your motion,
speak to in your body,
speaks to you,
and it all does all that,
at least in part through the dream.
And the dream is the birthplace
of the fully articulated idea.